"lol i wanna die why am i doing this?''
"One of the long ones?"
"Back here?"
"Yeah right back there."
All right, so I've been calling Paypal for...
Four months.
*Music Plays*
I've given them utilities with the address on it
I've given them my social security number, my id, a statement from the company on Company letterhead with
Signed by everyone I've given them the statement of information from the California secretary of state and they keep asking me for it
They keep saying resubmitted. Yes
usually once they realize that I submitted all the
Information they try to get a hold of compliance or one of their managers
and then they're unable to do so
compliance kicked me back a letter that says we are unable to verify the account information because the business name it's
Listed as the business itself which is exactly what I'm trying to change
And I can't just cancel the account and change it because there's actual money in there that I can't pull out
letter head
Yeah, so I've submitted that letterhead twice already.
okay let me check another place for that particular document. Bam! there it is, ok.
Let me just kind of review it for you.
Okay, so now she's Gonna call compliance
And she's gonna try to get ahold of them and hopefully she'll be able to get ahold of them
Which means that she'll be able to change it right now. If she's not able to get ahold of them right now
She's gonna pick up the phone and she's gonna go "I reached out to compliance, and
I wasn't able to get a hold of them so I can't change it right now, what i'll do is
I'll submit that information for you, and then hopefully compliance will just change it
And then they won't send you a letter or anything they'll just It'll just be ready to go in a couple business days."
and then tomorrow, I'll get an email from
Compliance that says "we're unable to change the business name because your business is listed as the business name."
"Here's a tip that can help solve a problem. The caps-lock on, or pushing the upper or lower ca-" "Jake, thanks so much for holding
I appreciate it" "No problem" "okay I think
I discovered what the problem is. There's
a couple documents that you sent in, um last month
um
Where you attached more than one page." "yeah" "and just the first page showed up"
and I see everything
but that letterhead letter asking us to request it." "okay,
So if I submit any other documentation it only accepts the first page?"
"In a perfect world, no it should take all of them."
"Is that I've submitted so much documentation at this point that the amount of storage that I'm allowed to upload is full"
"uh huh. I'll send you another link and you can attach it to that link, and then um, give us a call back, and finish and submit it, that way someone can review it
While you're on the phone. This can be handled today if we get what we need okay?" "Okay, Great. I will do that right now, bye."
So again a new problem presents itself in this thrilling epic of how we get this PayPal account reinstated.
I got an upload link.
"Hey Jake, have you seen Peter? I'm looking for him." "Uh yeah, I sent him into the back, to get a cable
for something, I don't know that was a while ago."
Peter? Pete-.... 42 Stop!
Think fast.
Wa- wait!
42!
No don't do it! please no!
Don't do it! 42 stop!
You were supposed to improve the Wrenders not
cancel them!
So I've submitted the final document. Hopefully. Now I'm calling them back.
"What is your first and last name?"
"Yeah, Jake Watson. So I've submitted all the documentation since
April."
"And so I've done that, because apparently it wasn't in the system."
"So I resubmitted that." *pre-recorded message plays* "Now she's calling compliance."
Um, I guess I'll... uh...
cross my fingers.
"All right, I completely understand and you know if you have any more problems feel free
to just call back or you can always email them at compliance at PayPal.com"
"Yup.
All righty."
And there you have it. Will compliance accept the documentation? we'll find out
Probably tomorrow morning when I get an email from them that says they have not been able to accept the documents because the business name
Is listed as the contact name.
"It's the end of summer here, and with that
Comes departure of our dear friend Peter. So all joking aside Peter
It's really been awesome having you here. Setting off to college, big moves, big times,
Big learning. You're gonna be a man."
"Gonna do some learning." "This also happens to be our hundredth episode, lots of big things
Coinciding. I hope you guys have really been enjoying watching this series, Peter
Thank you so much for partaking in all our crazy story ideas."
"Thank you for having me." "You'll probably see him in the next BTS
just because we have footage from that, that was filmed before this episode, so."
"Apologize the confusion."
"Sorry guys." "Oh, I didn't mean-- *chuckling* "I apologize"
"I'm going to school to get some sweet student loans. Gonna be paying those off for a while. Living the American dream."
"I'm gonna learn some film stuff. I'm gonna take a bunch of general Ed's that don't have anything to do with film and... uh
you know I'm going to, uh
explore my spirituality in San Francisco, so uh yeah."
"I think everyone liked him so." "Really good what?" "Dim Sum" "Dim Sum. Dim Sum what?"
"Is that food?" "Yes."
"Cool anyways. Good luck man
"I'm sure it's going to be a great time, and if people wanted to like follow you on like instagram or Youtube or whatever." "I can plug my things?" "You can plug your things."
"Okay um...
Carmichael is just gonna put a title right here"
"No no no, but it's not spelled like torpedo films. It spelled like T O R P E E T O
Films." "Like Peter, yeah."
That's what it should have been.
"So if you guys want to track Peter and his probably lack of uploading while he's busy at college
Go check out his channel um yeah."
Check it dude. Yeah college
"You know I'm expecting some sweet college vids." "Dude yeah there is going to be so many San Fran skyline shots."
"It's gonna be great."
"Are you gonna like, like warp stabilize it and like maybe drive under the bridge and like
see the-" "Oh my God. So many times." "How about the rest of you guys?"
"Yeah, yeah, well good times, when you want a summer job next summer if you happen to come back down to La..." "I'll be here."
"Alright, sweet" "Cool, also make sure to buy the LG G4." *Laughing*
"I can hear them."
"Traces of who I was. Who I could have been."
"When you're just one in a million, what makes you..."
Unique.
Special.
I need the answer.
Even if it takes seven and a half million years."